vaya qué lindo eres mira tus mejillas y
tu cabello y es contra 110 citas a
ciegas con fotos de la infancia hola
le pedimos a hannah que tuviera diez
citas a ciegas solo podía ver fotos de
la infancia de los chicos esther y
convertirte en la persona que eres ahora
es un proceso muy importante creo que mi
infancia me convirtió en la persona que
soy yo y el lugar donde crecí mis
pasatiempos y las cosas buenas que pasen
los chicos solo espero no sudar mucho
lista
ah
[Música]
i
efe
hola hola tenías un triciclo si estaban
de moda de dónde eres vengo de
washington en serio yo igual genial eres
muy linda si tenía solamente dos dientes
y tenía sólo dos pequeños a su mando
seis mil nuestro bebé feliz soy una
persona alegre tu camisa dice bong el
boy que se creo que dice view google
voice obvio que el boy que adora creo
que lo perdiste vestía sólo cuando eras
niño creo que lo hacían mis padres y
esto cambió con el tiempo o su de mis
padres si usas un overol genial mientras
sube es mejor una escalera parece esta
artista mi familia solía darme hojas en
blanco para que hiciera muchos dibujos
tú eres artista lo soy si amo las
cerámicas te gustaría enseñarle a
alguien claro vamos a enseñar podrías
enseñarme a mí es buena idea para una
estás comiendo tostadas con mermelada sí
sí hay un desorden lo que me encanta
porque los niños suelen ser así sin
ningún complejo me encanta la comida de
mis padres me encantaría ser capaz de
hacerla y llevarla al mismo nivel de
vista pequeño aquí te juro que no era
tan pequeño tuba pero dice amo a mi mami
muchas de mis camisas decían amo a mi
mamá en esa época te ves bien lejana
gracias johnny también te ves bien atrás
en especial en esta foto los cielos era
es tan lindo mira tus mejillas y tu
cabello
estabas tan pequeño no tenías más de
unas cuantas semanas si a esta obra me
gusta llamarla
hola quién habla hola a quien habla tu
nombre tiene algún significado
chayanne en persa antiguo era un nombre
que significaba digno o restas posando
como un rey en esta foto tal mente y
nada demasiado feliz
pueden oírme dios mío a mario lo siento
tengo una cita después de esto
si fin cómo te sentiste
esto apesta
respiren profundo
en esta foto estás usando anteojos mi
mamá me dijo que si los usa para atraer
y a las chicas eso creo que no funciona
pero pues creo que era un rumor porque
yo también pretendí que veía mal para
usar anteojos me estoy preguntando qué
estará pensando
haciendo así
era muy genial a esa edad cuál era tu
clase favorita cuando estabas en la
escuela amaba historia era como viajar
en el tiempo saber si tú tal vez el
receso a la hora de la siesta de otoño
es mi estación favorita la mía y wazin
todo se siente tan cálido y huele a
canela te gusta pasar más tiempo al aire
libre que en casa o claro que sí me
encanta escalar y ohio igual jugabas
baloncesto hice solo por un año no era
muy bueno jugaba bien hasta séptimo
grado ahora ni hablar de este elegante
en esta foto
y ese era nuestro uniforme me hacía
llamar un atleta en ese entonces
tu corte en esta foto quieres hablar de
ello en realidad no me mama corto mi
cabello hasta el noveno grado así que la
secundaria fue horrible para mí con los
y si no tranquila yo los superhéroes
parte del proceso no así es todo mejora
y sé lo que piensas en que estoy
pensando este chico parece un tonto
sabes sólo debes emocionado por el
trofeo solo digamos que ahora que veo
esta foto entiendo por qué se metían
conmigo los tiempos dime que no sé la
mejor foto que has visto es una melena
pero muy horrible no es así sentía que
debía mostrar tela para que veas todo el
crecimiento de chayanne segunda ronda
eliminaciones es el chasquido de tanos
esto es difícil son sólo niños en estas
fotos no puedo hacerlo yo ni
james si james 6
estoy molesto ahora el mundo vio mi foto
en secundaria y para nada quién sabe tal
vez alguien la ve
y le gusta dejarlo así seguro
dios qué difícil aaron
chayanne
lo siento mucho
[Música]
estoy hablando con debón
como ya hablamos del pasado me gustaría
saber cuáles son tus metas para el
futuro viene a los ángeles porque quiero
convertirme en actor en serio sabes algo
que yo también soy actriz de verdad si
quiero terminar con los estereotipos de
los actores asiáticos en eeuu largo
entiendo primero quiero decirte que
tienes un buen gusto
si te gusta la cerámica la salud y
tienes una banda cómo crees que todo eso
te engloba como persona a veces da un
poco de miedo tener gustos tan
diferentes puedes llegar a dispersar te
amo pero creo que soy un hermoso
desastre soy todas las cosas que me
gustan eso me permite relacionarme con
muchas personas y hacerlos sentir vistos
y escuchados pero hablemos de ti qué te
gustaría lograr en la vida mejorar mi
arte hasta el punto de poder enseñar a
otras personas solía ser tutor en la
escuela amaba esa dinámica genial muchas
gracias de bon bon
adiós mi hija es mía
falta poco inhalen
examen
escojo a chris
si a él de acuerdo crist escogieron
vaya vaya
que quieren verse si se ve bien
ahora
hola
soy crisis
viva ya es tan hermosa como el sonido de
su voz y me gustó nuestra conversación y
tu cabello es corto
no lo dejo que sea constantes
esto es genial o es cierto bueno sí lo
es sabía que era puesto por sus fotos es
una locura pero lo que me atrajo fue su
personalidad su pasión sus metas y soy
yo de bebé también
de piezas de ésta
pero
lleva yo era rubio era rubia el sí pero
luego se oscureció era rubio en serio
dos fotos no lo es es algo personal
mostrar tus fotos de la infancia así que
de esta forma puedes verlo ser un poco
vulnerables nos dirán en los comentarios
quién es el bebé más lindo de nosotros 3
soy yo yo yo yo soy el menor no soy tan
lindo ustedes
pero
lo
utilizan en los comentarios no sólo
sobre quién es el bebé más lindo sino
sobre lo que les gustó de este episodio
si no se ha suscrito al canal háganlo
díganle a sus amigos y así verán muchas
más cosas geniales ellos
jubilee vive más